[موسيقى]
انها ثمنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص وهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
ولايه جورجيا اذا تؤجل حسب السباق لمجلس
الشيوخ الى ديسمبر والجمهوريون قريبون من
السيطره على النواب
تقليم الاظافر يسبق حسم النتائج
الجمهوريون لبيض لن نعطي شيكا على بياض
لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا
تراجع ام حيله ماذا خلف الانسحاب الروسي
المفاجئ من خرسون اوكرانيا تشكك وتؤكد
اللامشرات على اي تحرك
اضرابات جديده في ايران والنظام يهدد
المحتجين ولاول مره تكتل الاصلاحي يدعو
الاستفتاء لحل الازمه
[موسيقى]
وصيت مؤقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اذا
انكشفت نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه عن تقدم طفيف للجمهوريين على
الديمقراطيين حتى الان فيما تم الاعلان
عنه في مجلس الشيوخ احتل الجمهوريون 49
مقعدا فيما احتل الديمقراطيون 48 مقعدا
وذلك بعد ان فاز الجمهوريون بولايه
ويسكانسون وتتبقى الان ثلاثه مقاعد في
مجلس الشيوخ هي غير محسومه وهي في جورجيا
اريزونا ونفادا فياريزون يتقدم
الديمقراطيون عبر السنه الحاليه ماركلي
على الجمهوريه
مصر
الديمقراطيين قد يتاخر بسبب مشاكل تقنيه
تسببت في اغلاق ابواب اللجان في احد
المقاطعات بالامس الامر الذي اغضب
الجمهوريين اما الحسن الحقيقي من المتوقع
ان يكون في جورجيا
في الاخيره يتقدم الجمهوري ادم على السنه
الديمقراطيه الحاليه
التي تبدو وانها ستخسر مقعدها اما في
جورجيافس سباق قريب للغايه بين السماء تر
الديمقراطيه
الحاليك والجمهوريه المدعوم من ترامب
هيرشي الوكر وبالتالي اعلنت السلطات بشكل
رسمي انها تتجه لجوله اعاده الانتخابات في
مجلس الشيوخ في السادس من ديسمبر اي جوله
ثانيه هناك اما على صعيد الانتخابات مجلس
النواب فكشفت سي ان عن حصول الجمهوريين
على اربعه مقاعد حتى الان في ما حصل
الديمقراطيون على 187 مقعدا ولتذ كيف انه
للفوز يجب الحصول على 2008
[موسيقى]
سبونج بوب
في ولاياتنا سينتقل الى السادس من ديسمبر
المقبل وهو سباق على مقعد عضو مجلس الشيوخ
بين رفيع
سنبدا التحضير لجوله الاعاده
حتى يوم الاثنين الموافق الثامن والعشرين
من نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
نتابع مشهد هذه النتائج الانتخابيه في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه مع شبكه مراسل
العربيه
ولا عنوان هو ان الديمقراطيون حرموا
الجمهوريين من فوز ساحق هذا ما سيقوله
الرئيس بيدن هنا في البيض الابيض خلال
ساعه تقريبا من الان طبعا هناك شعور
بالرضا لانه كانت التوقعات بان يمنع
الديمقراطيون بخساره كبيره جدا هذا لم
يتحقق سيحافظون على الاقل ربما سنرى اذا
جورج بالفعل في ولايه الاعاده او في جوله
الاعاده اعطت كما هو متوقع هذه الاصوات
للديمقراطيه سنعود الى 50 50 بمعنى 50
لصالح الجمهوريين و50 يديمقراطيه والصوت
الفاصل او الفارق هو لنائبه الرئيس كامله
هاريس لكن بالنسبه لمجلس النواب طبعا
نتوقع بان يكون هناك طبعا فوز للجمهوريه
لكنه فوز اسرائيل كيف المقاسي اعلى اليوم
قبل قليل ترشحه وكانه يريد ان يقول بانه
هو الوحيد الذي سيكون رئيس لمجلس النواب
وهي رساله للجمهوريين بالتحديد لكن انه
سيصعب حياه الرئيس من التشريعات خصوصا
الامور الداخليه ليس فقط في السياسه
الخارجيه التي قال كيف المكاتي باننا لن
نعطي البيت الابيض شيكا على بياض بالنسبه
للميزانيه التي يسيطر عليها النواب طبعا
برئاسه الجمهوريين اذا بالفعل تم هذا النص
لهم كما هو متوقع
حسين يبدو ان جورجياسات تاخر حسم هذه
المعركه بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
والتفاصيل
بالفعل صهيب وكما كان متوقع عن جورجيا هي
الساحه الانتخابيه الحاسمه على ما يبدو في
هذه الانتخابات التي قد تحدد الحزب الذي
سيطر على همم مجلس الشيوخ همم طبعا همم
نحن بدنا نعرف دوله لاعاده ستكون في
الثلاثه من همم
الان همم التحليلات كلها تشير او
المتعلقه خاصه بديمقراطيين تشير الى ان
ال- ال- الافضليه الان لرافاييل وارناق
بسبب ان الحاكم الجمهوري همم الذي فاز
بعيده انتخابه خلال انتخابات الحاليه همم
ابراهيم كامل لن يكون موجوده اختراع وهذا
لن يساعد همم هرش الواقر في المقابل همم
يرى الديمقراطيون انه اذا تم همم همم
او كان هناك مناصفه في همم في الباقي
الولايات في مجلس الشيوخ ذلك سيكون ايضا
لصالح ولكن هناك همم لغه ارقام تاريخيه هي
انه عام 1960 وحتى ع- عام 2020 كان هناك
احد 10 جوله اعاده فاز بها او فاز بسبعه
منها الجمهوريون ايضا الوضع الان يختلف عن
جوله عدله التي حدثت عام 2020 التي فاز
بهارناطه همم
الجمهوريو الديمقراطيون كانوا في موضع
الدفاع همم عن عن سياساتهم خلال حمله
الانتخابيه الماضيه في ظل الهجوم الجمهوري
عليهم والذين تتسلحوا بموضوع الاقتصاد
وبموضوع التضخم وايضا موضوع الجريمه ولكن
كل الامور طبعا الان سنبدا منذ اليوم نشهد
حمله انتخابيه من الطرفين حتى السادس
ديسمبر دعنا نذهب الى همم الغرب الامريكي
الى همم زميلتنا ريتا سليمان انت في
نيفادا ولكن لن اسالك عن النظافه اسالك عن
اريزونا ريتا يبدو انه هناك ايضا همم
تاخير هناك بالنسبه للنتائج ماذا انتظر
وماذا نتوقع
هناك باختصار معركه الان في ارينا همم اذا
ما كنت تذكر بالامس كان هناك همم اخطاء
تقنيه او اعطال تقنيه ادت همم
لاغلاق بعض المراكز همم الانتخابيه في
مقاطعه ماري كوبا كاونتي وهي همم التي تقع
من ضمنها العاصمه فينيكس في هذه هي
المقاطعه همم توقف التصويت
بضعه ساعات ولكن تم ااه من بعدها سماح
بالانتخابات
في همم المراكز نفسها ولكن اليوم همم
الحمله الانتخابيه للجمهوريين همم تقول
بانه هذا هو بسبب مع هذا التاخير والعطل
هو ما حصل همم جعلهم يخسرون للانتخابات
التي جمعت بالامس من هذه هي المراكز
تحديدا
اكتسابها الان وفرزها لمعرفه النتيجه
النهائيه كان هناك تهامات باعمال احتيال
في مقاس ما حصل امس ولكن خرج رئيس
المراقبين بالجيتس يقول بان هذا ليس صحيحا
ابدا واستغرب هذا الامر كون بالامس
المرشحه الجمهوريه لمنصب حاكمه الولايات
كاريلاك قد تقدمت هي وابليك ماسترز المرشح
جمهوري عن همم مجلس الشيوخ بدعوه قضائيه
لتمديد ساعات الاقتراع في هذه المقاطعه
تحديدا التي شهدت الاعطال التقنيه ولكن
المحكمه رفضت همم هذا هذه الدعوه وتسائل
البيت انه لماذا هذه الاتهامات همم
بالامس لم يكن عليه ذكر لها كل ما ذكر في
الدعوه التي تقدمت بالامس الى القضاء في
هذه المقاطعه كان له وقت الانتخاب والان
يتم الحديث عن همم عن اي اعمال في هذا همم
ذكره
بانه همم الدعوات لاحتماليه اي تزوير في
هذه المقاطعه كان همم من فتره حتى انه
الجمهوريين كان عندهم همم مثل الفرق امنيه
موسى لحالي حمايه المراكز وحمايه مراكز
البريد التي تجمع التصويت عبر البريد ولكن
القضاء منعهم ايضا نعود الى الضفه
الامريكيه الاخرى الى نيويورك طلال الحاج
همم نيويورك يعني ولايه تقليديه همم ولايه
زرقاء تصوت لصالح الديمقراطيين يبدو انه
ليس هناك مفاجاه وهمم الديمقراطيون
يحتفظون بمقعد حاكم نيويورك
نعم بالفعل على المستوى المحلي ما زال
الديمقراطيين
متفوقين على على الجمهوريين بنسبه الضعف
تقريبا في كل المجلس الشيوخ الخاص
بالولايه ومجلس الشعب او مجلس نوابها من
اهم سباقات كانت سباقات الاول للزعيم
الديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ شك شومر ضد
منافسين الجمهوري جوبانيا وتمكن الشمر من
الفوز بفارقه نتايه 10 نقطه بالرغم من
الاستطلاعات كانت تشك حتى في فوزي وقالوا
انه اذا فاز فيكون بنقطه او بنقطتين
وبالتالي سيظل شمر ممثلا للديمقراطيين في
مجلس الشيوخ وزعيما لهؤلاء جمركين اذا اذا
تمت النتيجه في مجلس الشيوخ 50 50
اما
السباق الثاني فهو فوز كاترين هوكل بمنصب
حاكم الولايه ابره صندوق الاقتراح هذه
المره وهي المره الاولى في تاريخ ولاده
يوكل عريق الذي ينتخب في سكان الولايه
حاكمه هو يوم تاريخي للمراه الامريكيه في
نيو كما تعرفون ان كافر تسلمت هذا المنصب
من حاكم الولايه اندرو كومو اثر استقالته
في شهر اغسطس من العام الماضي نتيجه فضائح
همم تحرش بموظفه نقطه واحده مهمه احب ان
اذكرها لو سمحت لي
النسب الرسميه للمشاركين في التصويت كانت
ضئيله وبالنسبه 28% بالرغم من اهميه هذه
الانتخابات في نيويورك صحيح ان المشاركين
في الانتخابات النصفيه من الناخبين فقل له
نسبهم بكثير عن نسب المشاركين في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كل اربع سنين ولكن لم
تبلغ اقل من 30% لعشرات الصينيين هذه
الارقام
رسميا وايضا في الولايات المتحده بلغت
المشاركه متوسطهها 36 وثلاثه في العاشره
في المئه وهي ضعيفه ويذكر المؤرخون انها
لم تصل هذا المستوى منذ عام 1942 شبكه
مراسلين العربيه اذن من نيويورك نيفادا
واشنطن وجورجيا طلال الحاج للتليمان حسين
الطاوضي وناديه بالبيسي شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا
[موسيقى]
ولا شك ان نتائج هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
ستحمل معها رياح تغيير ستعيد رسم سياسات
الولايات المتحده على الصعيد الدولي يبدو
ان نجاح الجمهوريين في الانتخابات النصيه
سيغير المواقف الامريكيه في العديد من
الملفات فما هي هذه الملفات التي ستتغير
تاتي الحرب الاوكرانيه على راس الملفات
التي قد تشهد تغيرا للموقف الامريكي لاسيه
ما على مستوى الدعم خاصه الجمهوريين على
المجلسين ستحرم بيدن من حريه تمرير
القرارات وستعد من نهجه المعلن في الدعم
لا مشروط والذي يكلف الميزانيه الامريكيه
الشيء الكثير
وما يعزز هذا الطرح هو كلام رئيس كتله
النواب الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب قبل ما
كارتي الذي حذر من انه لن يعطي الاداره
الامريكيه شيكا على بياض لمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا فضلا عن ان 57 نائب جمهوريه
صوتوا ضد مشروع اوكرانيا مساعدات العسكريه
بقيمه اربعين مليار دولار في شهر مايو
الماضي
وثانيا الملفات الخارجيه المنتظر تاثرها
بعد هذه الانتخابات الاتفاق النوويه مع
ايران فا النواب والشيوخ الجمهوريون الجدد
يدينون اغلبهم بالولاء يدينون بالولاء
ترامب الذي كان في الاساس اللي اتفاق
النوويه سنه 2018 ما يعني ان اعاده احياء
الاتفاق قد تكون ضربا من المستحيل علما ان
المفاوضات متعثره في الوقت الراهن وملف
خارجي اخر قد يتغير فيه الموقف الامريكي
وهو الدور القيادي داخل حيث شمال الاطلس
حيث يرى الجمهوريون بشكل عام ان اوروبا
بحاجه الى تعزيز قوتها اكثر وعدم الاعتماد
بشكل مغال فيه على الدعم الامريكي المهيمن
داخل الحلف
اخر هذه الملفات ملف المناخ فرئيس
الجمهوري السابق كان اقل التزاما اتجاها
قضايا المناخ قياسا الرئيس الحالي ما يعني
ان سيطره الجمهوريين الذين يتبنون نفس
رؤيه ترامب يعني تراجعا خراط امريكا في
ملفات المناخ
[موسيقى]
معنى من واشنطن البحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات حسين عبد الحسين اهلا بكم
العربيه
لماذا لم يحصل اكتساح جمهوري كما كان
متوقعا
طبعا الاسباب عديده ولكن اعتقد ان اهمها
هو ابتعاد الامريكيين من الحسبين عن
اجندات المتطرفه اي اقصى اليمين اقصى
اليسار وانتصاقهم بالوسطين ان كان مثلا
المحافظ الجمهوري وهو من المحافظين في
جورجيا او ااه يعني التخلي عن ووكر يعني
رجل
ترامبولو في نفس الولايه طبعا
الديمقراطيين الوسطين هناك ملاحظه انه
معظم الناجحين هم من الوسطيين من الحسبين
ولذلك هناك شبه اقصاء لاقصى يمين واقصى
اليسار من الحسبه نعم طيب نتحدث الان على
تاثير هذه النتائج المنتظره صحيح في مجلس
الشيوخ المساله الحسم قد تتاخر الى ديسمبر
بسبب ولايه جورجيا همم ولكن يبدو هناك
تقدم للجمهوريين في مجلس النواب بشكل واضح
في مجلس الشيوخهم ب 49 من اصل 50 همم
والديمقراطينين عنده 48 ولكن ديمقراطين
لديهم افضليه انه نائبه الرئيس همم يمكن
ان تحقق الاغلبيه للديمقراطيين في حال ما
حصل التقدم المنتظر للجمهوريين ولو بدون
اكتساح في مجلس النواب كيف سيؤثر ذلك على
الملفات السياسيه الخارجيه لامريكا
مجلس النواب وحده لا يمكن السيطره على
اجنده الخارجيه خصوصا ان ضل مجلس الشيوخ
في هذه الديمقراطيين طبعا لمجلس الشيوخ
قدره اكبر على مواضيع مثل تعيينات السفراء
تعيينات الخارجيه تعيينات وزاره الدفاع
وزاره الخارجيه هذه كلها الامور في اي
دمشق وان ضل في هذه الديمقراطين هذا يعني
انه لا قدره للجمهوريين على همم يعني وقف
سياسات معينه نعم موضوع اخر هو انه حتى
يتمكن الكونغرس مثلا اجبار الرئيس بنفرض
على وقف تمويل حرب اسبانيا
سيحتاج الجمهوريون الى الغرفتين لا يمكن
اقرار مشروع قانون بغرفه واحده وحتى بعد
اقرار مشروع القانون يمكن للرئيس يعني
لديه حق الفيتو ولكن كانت هناك غرفه واحده
لا امل اصلا المشروع حتى يخرج من الكونغرس
ويذهب الى الرئيس بغرفه واحده لا اعتقد
انه لدى جمهوريين قد اكيد طبعا لديهم قدره
على تحريض الراي العام ولفت الضوء يعني في
مواضيع معينه ضد بيضين وسياسه نعم طيب
استاذ حسين المساله اخرى كنا نسمع اصواتا
من الجمهوريين يقولون انه اذا ما حصلوا
على الاغلبيه في الكونغرس فانهم سيذهبون
باتجاه مساءله الرئيس وفتح تحقيق حول
انشطه نجله هانتر في اوكرانيا وهناك من
ذهب بعيدا انه سيطالب بعزل الرئيس
هل ترى هذا يعني وارد الحصول
المساءله شبه اكيده وجلسات الاستماع مساله
مسؤولين
مساله بايد ان اعتقد انها شبه اكيده ولكن
هل يمكن لمجلس النواب الذهاب بعيدا يعني
الى تبني قرار خلق قرار الخلع يحتاج حكما
الى غرفتين لا يمكن ان يتم طبعا اين نحن
قبل عامين راينا كيف خلع الديمقراطيون
ترامب وذهبوا من مجلس النواب سيرا الى
مسجد
الشيوخ لا يمكن الخلاء ولكن اعتقد ان انا
يمكن لمجلس النواب احداث ضرر كبير لصوره
بيضا امام امريكيين في يعني امام الراي
العام وعرقلت يعني وامتصاص جزء كبير من
طاقه هذه الاداره موجوده هذه الاداره على
احتواء هذه المعارضه لانه هذه المعارضه
سيصبح لها لديها صوت يعني اصبح كامل مكان
فيه هو حامل مطرقه مجلس النواب رئيسا
لمجلس النواب باسم الغالبيه الجمهوريه
سيصبح لديها صوت ويسمح لنا لديها قدره على
تحقيق ولا استصدار يعني مذكرات تحقيق وما
الى هنالك ولكن لا اعتقد انه هذا يتعدى
حيز يعني الاعلام والراي العام ليصل الى
خطوات فعليه لمنع بايديا او لخلع بايجن او
لفرد اي خطوه اخر سؤال باختصار تاثير
سيطره الجمهوريه على مجلس النواب التي
ماتت بشكل مؤكده على احياء الاتفاق النووي
هل لهذا تاثير ام لا يمكن لبايدن احياء
الاتفاق من دون العوده الى مجلس النواب
اولا اسمح لي ان اشير انه الكونجرس بغرفتي
بغض النظر عن الحزب هو دائما معارض لهذه
الاتفاقيه ان كان في زمن باراك اوباما او
في زمن ترامب او حتى اليوم ولذلك راينا ان
نبايض المساعده الى المفاوضات خارجيا
وكانت الفكره يعني اصلا هي الاتفاقيه مرت
في مجلس الامن ولم تمر يوما في الكونجرس
الكونجرس بغلبيه الحزبين هو ضد الاتفاقيه
لذلك اعتقد انه بايدا سيحاول تمرير هذه
الاتفاقيه هذا يعني ان وافقت ايران اصلا
سيحال تمرين اتفاقيه كما حصل في الماضي
عبر مجلس الامن ومن دون الدخول في همم من
خلال الكاميرا برنس ولكن قد يتمكن
اصبح جمهوريه قد يتمكن اثار الضجيج كافي
ربما باقناء الرئيس انه هذا هذه الاتفاقيه
لا تستهل يعني انفاق او صرف رصيد سياسي
عليها
من واشنطن البحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه حسين عبد الحسين شكرا جزيلا
لك
تتقيد القرارات العسكريه للرئيس الامريكي
الى حد كبير في حاله خساره حزمه الاغلبيه
في غرفتي الكونجرس الشيوخ والنواب بماذا
يخبرون التاريخ عن علاقه الحروب التي كانت
الولايات المتحده طرفا فيها او دائما لاحد
الخصوم والانتخابات التشريعيه
[موسيقى]
انتخابات التجديد النصفي تتزامل مع الحرب
في اوكرانيا التي قوضت اقتصاد العالم 30
انتخابات النصفيه الجاره في القرن الماضي
في الولايات المتحده تزامل بعضها مع حروب
او نزاعات عسكريه شاركت فيها امريكا بشكل
مباشر او غير مباشر وانعكست على نتائجها
في الاثني عشر جوله من جولات التجديد
النصفي التي خسرها حزب الرئيس
الحربان العالميتان القطا بظلالهما
القادمه على الاقتصاد الامريكي وكانت
المحصله خساره الحزب الديمقراطي اغلبيه
مجلس الشيوخ النواب في استحقاقي تجديد
النصفي عام
1918 و 20 1946
اما الحزب الجمهوري فاخسر اغلبيه الغرفتين
اثناء سيطرته على الرئاسه الامريكيه عام
1986 و 20990 وهي الانتخابات التي جرت
بالتزامل مع الحرب السوفيتي على افغانستان
والحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
صحيح ان اتينا الحربيين لم تتدخل فيهما
واشنطن بشكل مباشر الا ان دعمها لاحد
طرفيها لم يتوقف ابان فتره حكم بوش الام
[موسيقى]
اما العام 2012 وكان الوضع استثنائيا خلال
المده الاولى لبوش الابن وفي اعقاب هجمات
ال 11 من سبتمبر تجمع الامريكيون خلفه حزب
الرئيس وفاز الجمهوريون باغلبيه بسيطه
بلغت ثمانيه مقاعد في مجلس النواب لكن
لاحقا على جورج بوش الابن نفس معاناه ابيه
ففي اول انتخابات عقبه حربي العراق
وافغانستان خاسره حزبه الجمهوريه اغلبيه
الكونجرس بغرفتي في انتخابات عام 2006
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه تضارب الروسيه
حول المفاوضات مع اوكرانيا مره منفتحون
واخرى الحوار شبه مشلول
اهلا بكم من جديد على تخومه
اوكرانيا وروسيا للمعركه المنتظره وبتت
المدينه وكانها قلعه عسكريه اتجهت كل
الانظار اليها في الاونه الاخيره وجرى
الحديث كثيرا عن انها ستشهد معركه حاسمه
وستكون وشيكا معركه القيله انها تسير على
درب معركه الشهيره فما الذي يجري الان
مفاجاه فجرتها روسيا او ربما تكون حيله
من دون سابق انذار امرت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بسحب قواتها من خرصه كيف شككت
واكدت انها لم ترى اي مؤشر على انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من المدينه لكن تبقى هذه
الخطوه واحده من اكبر عمليات الانسحاب
الروسيه وربما تشكل نقطه تحول في الحرب
في واحده من اكبر عمليه الانسحاب الروسي
التي قد تشكل نقطه تحول في حرب تقترب من
نهايه شهرها التاسع موسكو توجه قواتها
بترك الضفه اليمنى لنهر ديني برو في منطقه
خرسنا الاوكرانيه وتوجه هيسارا وزير
الدفاع الروسي امر بتنفيذ الانسحاب اقتراح
من قائد العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
الجنرال سيرجيو روفيكن الذي اقر بانه ليس
قرارا سهلا الخطوه الروسيه جاءت بعد تعرض
خارج لهجوم اوكرانيا مضاد منذ اسابيع ان
شهدت مواجهات ضاريه في الايام الاخيره
عليها الرؤوس في اوكرانيا بالكامل منذ
اطلاق العمليات العسكريه في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
وكانت الى جانب ثلاث مناطق اوكرانيه اخرى
ضمتها اليها موسكو بعد استفتاء لقي
انتقادات دوليه واسعه في وقت ابدا فيه
الكريم لان استعداده للتفاوض مع اكياف لكن
مع مراعاه الحقائق في الوقت الراهن حقائق
بدات تتغير مثل ما حدث في خرسان بلال
الوجداني العربيه
لماذا امرت روسيا بسحب قواتها من خيرسون
التي كانت على وشك ان تبدا ما سمي بام
المعارك في اوكرانيا
بالفعل تفاجئ شارع الروسي بقرار سحب
القوات الروسيه من الضفه الغربيه في كلسون
وترك مدينه مركز المحافظه التي انضمت
روسيا قبل شهر ونصف فقط والتي دخلتها
القوات الروسيه في اوائل ازار السابق وكذا
هناك اداره الروسيه وكان هناك سيطره روسيه
هذا القرار مع كل ذلك لا يمكن ان نسمي هذا
القرار مفاجاه لان في اول يوم تعيين في
دراسه
القائد العسكري في اوكرانيا وذلك قبل شهر
شويه
يجتمع الخبراء العسكريين والمحللين في
الراي ان امام جيلان سولا بيكين خيارات
صعبه جدا نظرا
للموقف الميداني
اول شيء هي مقسمه الى قسمين
بنهر وهنا جسر واحد فقط يربط الشترين همم
وتم تدمير هذا الجسر بصواريخ
التي استخدم لها القوات الالكترونيه نعم
امريكيه السنه التي استخدمها القوات
الافراديه
الى الضفه الاخرى من نهر
هل يفهم من هذا انه
انتهى الامر يعني روسيا ستسلم بعدم سيطرته
على الضفه الاخرى من النهر ام هذه مجرد
حيله ينتجها الجنرال الجديد الذي تسلم
العمليه
حتى يباغت الاوكرانيين
سكان المدنيين من الضفه اليمنى الى الضفه
اليسرى تم هذا القرار قبل اسبوعين
يعني اكثر من اسبوع
من قبل الاداره المدنيه من ثم تم القرار
باجلاء المدنيين من الضفه الغربيه همم من
ثم تم نقل المؤسسات الاداريه ولا اخره قبل
يومين تم قطع ايه مواصلات يعني عبر الجذور
العائمه التي بنيتها قوات الهندسه
العسكريهم يعني ماذا نفهم من كل هذا همم
سياده العقيد
بالنسبه للحيله لا اعتقد انها لان هذا هي
ضربه اعلاميه قويه جدا تؤثر على سمعه
البيات البلاد وسمعت قالت الاجراءات
الاداريه والقرارات ونوامر العسكريه لان
اييي محافظه كرسون هي انضمت الى روسيا في
الاولى السابق بقرار الرئيس بوتين وكان
هناك استفتاء وهمم
قانونيه يعني بموجب الدستور الروسي محاوله
تعتبر محافظه روسيه اعراض الروسيه التي
تفقدونيا
هل يمكن ان تكون هذه خطوه اذا لم تكون
حيله عسكريه لمباغته الاوكرانيين هل يمكن
ان تكون خطوه لفتح باب التفاوض ربما مع
الاوكرانيين همم وانها هذه الحرب ام هذا
افراد في التفاؤل
لا اتاكد انه اييه المفاوضات
ممكن اصلا لان
لما تعلن موسكو تغيير اهداف العسكريه هي
هي تبقى نفسها وكيف تصير على تنفيذ شروطها
وشروطها ايضا واضحه وغير مقبوله من قبل
موسكو اطلاقا
وهناك الطرف المؤثر همم الغربي الذي يجبر
كييف على
مطاوله الحرب لان الحرب هي المواجهه
العسكريه ليست همم بين موسكو بينما هي
بدايه الحرب العالميه الثالثه بين موسكو
والهرب وبالفعل هناك اكثر من 50 دوله
حاليا بشكل او باخر بهذه العمليات
القتاليه عن طريق التزويد الاسلحه
والذخائر والتدريب الكادر
والدعم المادي والى اخره
[موسيقى]
الحرب العالميه بدون سوف تكون طويله عنيفه
لعبه للمفاوضات على كل حال
شكرا جزيلا لكم من موسكو كنت معنا العقيد
السابق في الجيش الروسي سر جاي شاكو
[موسيقى]
ومع هذا التغير المفاجئ في معركه خرسن
وبعيدا عن ارض المعركه هل ستجلس موسكو
وكيف الى طاوله المفاوضات من اجل ايجاد
حلل دبلوماسيه للحرب في اوكرانيا كما كنا
نتحدث مع السيد شاكر
تصعب الاجابه عنه في ظل تضارب الاخبار
والتنبؤات حول امكانيه اللجوء الى الحاله
التفاوض فمن واشنطن ورده
الى التفاوض حيث قال السفير الروسي لدى
الولايات المتحده
ان الحوار بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
شبه مشلول وان المسؤولين الامريكيين لا
يتحدثوا مع روسيا حول اوكرانيا دون
مشاركته
وياتي كلام السفير الروسي لدى الولايات
المتحده عكس ما ورد في تقارير صحفيه اخرى
اشارت الى ان اوكرانيا خففت من شروطها
لقبول المفاوضات مع روسيا حيث ذكرت صحيفه
بوليتكو ان الاداره الامريكيه ضغطت على
زنسكي لكي يشطب من قائمه شروطي بدء الحوار
شرط عدم التفاوض مع التوتر
وكنز الاسكي طرح خمسه شروط لبدء المفاوضات
مع روسيا ومن ضمنها لم يرد همم ذكر
استحاله المفاوضات لم يرد الذكر في حاله
المفاوضات اذن مع الرئيس بوتين وجاءت
الشروط الخمسه كالتالي استعاده وحده اراضي
البلاد احترام ميثاق منظمه الامم المتحده
تعويض الاضرار الناجمه عن الحرب معاقبه كل
مجرم حرب واعطاء ضمانات لعدم تكرار احد
في المقابل واحد عكس تصريحات السفيره روسي
قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان موسكو لا تزال
مستعده للتفاوض معك يعني
اكدت ان موسكو لم ترفض المفاوضات ابدا
مشيله الى ان امداد الغرب اوكرانيا
بالسلاح يؤثر بشكل مباشر على استعداد
اكياف للمفاوضات
وبالحديث يعني المساعدات الغربيه كشفت
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل لافندر
لاين اليوم ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيقدم
حزمه دعم لاوكرانيا بقيمه 18 مليار يورو
والعمل المقبل واوضحت بندر لاين ان
التمويل سيقدم على دفعه منتظمه للمساعده
على تعافي ثياب على الامد القصير ودعم
المؤسسات تمهيدا الانضمام اخرى لعضويه
الاتحاد الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
الى ايران الان وفي ظل تواصلي وتمدد
الاحتجاجات ضد النظام
الرئيسي لتيار الاصلاح السلطات الى تنظيم
استفتاء للخروج من الازمه الداخليه
النتيجه عن الاحتجاجات التي بدات قبل
اسابيع في عقب مقتل الشابه مساء امينه
اتضم الجبهه الاصلاحيه التي طلبت
بالاستفتاء شخصيات المقربه من الرئيس
السابق محمد خاتمي كما حبه الجبهه
الاصلاحيه السلطات على اجراء التغيرات
الفوريه
للماده 59 من الدستور لاجراء استفتاء
كمخرج للازمه كما اشارت في الوقت ذاته الى
ضروره عقد حوار فعال على المستوى الوطني
للخروج من هذه الاسعار
وفي الاثناء وفي مواجهه الاحتجاجات
المستمرات في ايران رفع النظام سقف القمع
ولجا الى التصعيد فبينما نفذ النظام حكما
اعدام بحق متظاهرين اثنين في زهدان بعد
ادانتهما بالقيام باعمال ارهابيه وزعزعه
الامن على خلفيه الاحتجاجات هدد الجيش
الايراني بطرد ما يصفهم بمطيري الشغب في
البلاد وقال قائد القوات البريه للجيش
الايراني
شغب لن يكون لهم مكان في البلاد اذا امر
المرشد بحمله اكثر صرامه ضد المتظاهرين
وفي المقابل تحدى المحتجون كل وسائل القمع
والقتل والتهديد ونظموا اضرابا واسع
النطاق في مدن محافظه كردستان غرب ايران
في ذكرى الاربعين لمقتل متظاهرين بمدينه
ذهبان برصاص قوات الامن خلال الاحتجاجات
وشمال الاضراب مدن كارمن شئ وسلندرش
واضمن حملته في قمع الاحتجاجات استهدف
نظام الايراني بشكل منهجي الصحفيين
والصحفيات بحسب منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود
التي اكدت ان نصف صحفيين الذين اعتقلهم
النظام منذ دلاع الاحتجاجات هم من النساء
بينهم اثنتان تواجهان عقوبه الاعدام كشفت
المنظمه ان النظام اعتقلت 42 صحفيا بينهم
15 صحفيه وطالبت بالافراج عنهم دون قيود
او شرط
من جانبه قال رئيس المجلس الاوروبي يشارل
ميشيل لان الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث في الوقت
الراهن فرض مزيد من العقوبات ضد السلطات
الايرانيه المسؤوله عن قمع الاحتجاجات
وخلال كلمه له امام البرلماني
الاوروبيدانا ميشيل عنف السلطات الايرانيه
ضد المظاهرات السنويه
يجب على الاتحاد الاوروبي اجهزه الامن
الايرانيه ضد المحتاجين السلميين لن ننسى
اعجابنا بشجاعه النساء والفتيات
الايرانيات في كفاحهن للحريه والكرامه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه ازمه لجوء على
الابواب المتوسط مزدحم من جديد بقوارب
الموت
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه كشف
مارك زوكربيرج رئيس التنفيذي لشركه ميتا
ملكه فيسبوك عن قرار تسريحى اكثر من
11,000 من الموظفين وحمل ذكر برج في رساله
الى الموظفين نفسه مسؤوليه هذه القرارات
واصفا اياها باحدى اصعب التغييرات في
تاريخ
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا لدينا تحديث جديد لنتائج
انتخابات منتصف الولايه في امريكا المزيد
من المقاعد يحصدها الحزب الجمهوري اذا في
مجلس النواب هو الان عند
206 مقاعد مقابل 177
للديمقراطيين للتفكيرهم بحاجه ل 218
للحصول على الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب وهناك
52 وقعدا في النواب ما تزال اذا قيد
المنافسه الوضعيه في مجلس الشيوخي على
حالها 49 مقعد للجمهوريه 48 للديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
تغيرات والمناخ لن تتسبب في جعل الارض
مكانا غير صالح للعيش قد تخطف ارواح
الالاف وكاله البيئه الاوروبيه حضرت من ان
90000 اوروبيه قد يموتون سنويا بسبب موجات
الحرب حلول نهايه القرن الحليب في ما
وصفته باكبر تهديد صحيا مرتبط اشاره وكاله
البيئه الاوروبيه الى ان التوافر عوامل
عده بينها موجات الحرب وشيخوخه السكان
المتزايده وتسارع التنميه الحضاريه جعل
الاوروبيين اكثر عرضه لتبيعات ارتفاع درجه
الحراره وقد اعلنا المكتب الاوروبي في
منظمه الصحه العالميه انه في صيف 2020
سجلت ما لا يقل عن 15,000 وفاه في اوروبا
مرتبطه مباشره بموجات الحرب
[موسيقى]
عدد موجات اللجوء وقوارب الموت وسعونا
للهجره الى الضفه الاوروبيه في مشهد
يعيدنا الى عام 2015 في اوجي ازمه اللجوء
وكاله الاتحاد الاوروبي اعلنت ان عدد
المتقدمين للحصول على الحمايه الدوليه في
اوروبا وصل الى مستويات كبيره لم تشهد
القاره منذ اللجوء اكثر من مليون شخص
اليها قبل سبع سنوات واعلامه الوكاله ان
حوالي
84,500 شخص تقدموا بطالبات لجوء في اغسطس
الماضي في 27 دوله اوروبيه فيما طلب حوالي
من افغانستان ومن سوريا يدخلون عبر منطقه
غرب البلقان او من البحر المتوسط
[موسيقى]
الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
ولايه جورجيا تؤجلوا حسم السباق لمجلس
الشيوخ الى شهر ديسمبر والجمهوريون قريبون
من السيطره على النواب
تقليم الاظافر يسبق حسم النتائج
الجمهوريون لن نعطيه شيكا على بياض
لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا
ماذا خلف الانسحاب الروسي المفاجئ من
خرسون اوكرانيا
اضرابات جديده في ايران والنظام يهدد
المحتجين ولاول مره تكتل الاصلاحي يدعو
الاستفتاء لحل الاسماء
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم على المشاهده الى اللقاء